Before his death in California in 1991,
a man named William Kane wrote a letter
to the children from his first marriage
and to his fiancee, Deborah.
It read,
"I address this to my children
because although I have only two of you,
Everett and Katie,
it may be that Deborah decides,
as I hope she will,
to have a child by me after my death.
I have been assiduously generating
sperm samples for that eventuality.
If she does, then this letter
is for my posthumous offspring as well,
with the thought that I have
loved you in my dreams,
even though I never got to see you born.”
What happened after William Kane's death
was a lawsuit that would
forever change the law.
His ex-wife and adult children argued
that Deborah should not be allowed
to use the sperm samples.
They should be destroyed.
And a trial court agreed with them.
But Deborah appealed,
and a California appellate court
agreed with her,
finding that William Kane, and all of us,
have the right to use our DNA
after our death,
even to have children.
I am sure everyone in this room
has let their loved ones know
if they can use their DNA
to have a kid after they die, right?
OK, probably not yet.
But what happens if we don't tell anyone?
If we don't write it down?
And what happens when a couple creates
embryos together for use down the road,
then divorces
or eggs and sperm are mixed up
or an embryo transferred
to the wrong woman?
Because all of these things have happened.
Thanks to advances in technology,
there are more ways to try to have a baby.
But the law has lagged behind.
And because the law
hasn't kept up with the technology,
it's hurting people:
Families trying to conceive,
donors and surrogates trying to help them
and the children born
into these wild situations.
And one day it could affect
you or your loved ones.
I'm an attorney,
probably not surprising
by my knowledge of eggs,
sperm and the law.
I started my career
in the investment management group
of a large international firm,
forming hedge funds.
At parties, when asked
what I did for a living,
my answer was generally followed
by glances around the room
for someone more interesting to talk to.
But that time I was surrounded by people
thinking about having babies.
From my housemates, who were a gay couple,
to my sister and her husband
struggling with infertility.
And I learned about assisted
reproductive technology law.
I had the chance to read
through an egg donation agreement,
and it blew my mind.
So many questions I had never thought of.
What if an egg donor goes through
a single retrieval procedure
and has 20 eggs retrieved?
Not a crazy number.
Could those eggs be donated
to 20 different families?
Could each of those families
have a child genetically related to her?
What about disclosure and future contact?
Would she know the children?
Would the children know each other?
I was fascinated.
Way more interesting than hedge funds.
(Laughter)
But the law in this area
will leave your head spinning.
Even the definition of what is an embryo
is inconsistent and contradictory
from state to state.
In Louisiana, an embryo is defined
as a juridical person.
What's that?
Even the lawyers aren't really sure
what a juridical person is.
But we do know that it means that embryos,
stored in tanks
at -321 degrees Fahrenheit,
have the right to sue people.
(Laughter)
And don't think they won't do it.
Last year, celebrity actress
Sofia Vergara of "Modern Family" fame
and my favorite, "Smurfs,"
was sued by her embryos.
She had gone through fertility treatment
with her ex-fiancé, Nick Loeb,
when they were a couple.
They had two remaining embryos
from their IVF process
stored in a clinic in Los Angeles.
The consent forms they signed were clear:
neither could use the embryos
without the other’s consent.
At this point, Vergara had moved on,
married the actor from
"Magic Mike," Joe Manganiello.
She did not want those embryos being used.
Loeb, on the other hand,
was doing everything in his power
to win rights to the embryos.
After losing in California court,
he formed a trust
for the embryos in Louisiana.
He even named the embryos
Emma and Isabella,
and had them file a lawsuit
against Vergara,
demanding that they be brought to birth.
(Audience murmurs)
Ultimately, the lawsuit was dismissed
for lack of jurisdiction,
meaning Louisiana wasn't the right
place to hear the case.
The embryos were
in Los Angeles, California.
Neither Loeb nor Vergara
lived in Louisiana.
But given Louisiana's definition
of embryos as people,
it would have been
fascinating, and concerning,
if the court had been able
to rule on the case.
Of course, these were celebrities.
So we got to read
about their case in the news.
But it could happen to anyone
who's gone through IVF.
By contrast to the idea
that embryos are people,
other laws and judges
treat embryos as property.
In Texas, a probate judge
was forced to determine
the legal properties of 11 embryos
when a couple was murdered,
leaving behind their embryos
and their two-year-old son.
The judge determined
that embryos have value
and therefore were property
and should go to the couple's heir,
the two-year-old,
to determine what to do with them
when he turned 18.
That's a heavy responsibility
for an 18-year-old.
Does he transfer them to a surrogate
and raise his genetic siblings?
Does he donate them to others?
Does he forget about them entirely?
Not likely that his parents
were thinking about these questions
when they formed those embryos.
Aside from struggling
for the definitions of eggs,
sperm, embryos and who can use them,
the law especially struggles
when there are mix-ups in the lab.
In 2018,
a woman in New York, pregnant with twins,
was surprised at her
ultrasound appointment
when her obstetrician congratulated her
on having two boys.
You see, she had gone
through IVF in California
and there, her embryos had been tested
and shown to be two female embryos.
She called the clinic, but they said,
"Don't worry about it,
ultrasounds are frequently inaccurate.
You're having two girls."
But she gave birth to two boys.
And they didn't look
like her or her husband.
They did genetic testing.
She was not genetically related,
nor was her husband.
In fact, the twins weren't even
related to each other.
(Audience gasps and laughs)
Across the country,
a woman in California
got a call from her fertility clinic.
It had been about nine months
since she'd gone through
a failed embryo transfer.
She thought she was being asked
to come in for routine testing,
but was met with a roomful
of doctors, lawyers,
mental health professionals
that told her there'd been a mistake.
Her embryo had been transferred
to another patient,
and her genetic son
had been born in New York.
One of the twins.
A judge in New York determined
that the birth parents
were not the legal parents
to the children.
Instead,
the woman in California and her husband
were legal parents to one of the twins,
and another couple entirely
were legal parents to the other twin
because they were the genetic parents.
But a similar thing happened in Italy
with the exact opposite result.
There, two embryos were transferred
to the wrong patient
and a judge determined
that the birth parents
were the legal parents to the children
and the genetic parents
had no legal rights at all
to their own genetic children.
It's time for the law to change.
Here in Colorado,
our lone egg and sperm donation
statute has the language
"a wife with her husband's consent."
(Laughter)
It's a little offensive
to us liberated women,
but also doesn't include
single parents by choice
or LGBTQ parents.
It also doesn't include those
who donate their embryos
or those who receive embryos
to have a child.
What can we do besides
advocating for better laws?
We can think carefully
about our own reproductive material.
Every adult knows
that they should have a will,
even if they haven't done it yet.
A will lets those we leave behind
know what to do with our assets
and our possessions.
But most wills don't include
an invaluable asset,
our reproductive material.
And that leaves loved ones confused
and facing inconsistent laws.
For instance, in 2019,
a West Point cadet named Peter Zhu
was in a tragic ski accident.
His family begged the hospital
and then a judge
to let them retrieve his sperm.
They explained to the judge
that their son had always
wanted to have children,
and moreover, it was of vital
cultural importance to them
to continue their family line.
The judge was persuaded.
He issued the order to allow
the son's sperm to be retrieved
and later used for conception purposes.
But here in Colorado,
the law is not the same.
In the last few years,
at least twice it's happened
where a man was taken
to the hospital before his death
and the request by a spouse
to have his sperm retrieved was denied
because he didn't have
a consent on file with the hospital.
But in another case
where a man died suddenly
and was taken to the coroner,
his spouse's request to have
his sperm retrieved was granted
because the coroner is not subject
to the same policies and procedures
as a hospital.
So if you think you might allow someone
to have a child with your DNA
after your death,
or you don't want them to,
tell them.
Write it down, grab a napkin,
put it on a napkin, send a text.
No matter how strange that text may look.
(Laughter)
It happens more often than you think.
We think more carefully
about organ donation,
but this is just as important.
I bet you didn't think
you need to include this in your will.
The world has changed.
The technology is here,
and it will only keep advancing.
And this isn't the only area
where technology is outpacing the law.
We need to challenge ourselves
to think carefully
about what these innovations
mean to ourselves,
to our families, to our children
and to future children,
whether they're genetically
related to us or not.
Thank you.
(Applause)